you have a door
I if I had children I would not be able
to stay on the internet I could have
three I could have ten just what's your
message to the women because a lot of
you a lot of your videos seem very much
kind of aimed at guys yeah
I've got a property company I've also as
you know got a training company
of my customers yeah or women good
killing it in property absolutely
absolutely smashing it my wife is my
business partner amazing we've been
married eight years happily married
perfect brilliant marriage yeah good
she's helped me get a lot richer yeah
we're business partners do you not think
that the way you are you know referring
to women as [ __ ] do I refer to
women's [ __ ] yes you do okay well
first things first let's talk about that
if I if I make a joke or I say oh yeah
I can't you have to give an example
where I even said that because I don't
think I say that publicly but or I don't
think I say that often but every rap
song says women are [ __ ] anyway like
I'm not saying that it's okay to say I'm
not saying that I view women that way
but I'm to sit here and say that I call
women [ __ ] when every single song on
the radio is talking about stabbing
people and calling women [ __ ] is kind
of hypocritical I don't I don't call
women [ __ ] anyway I don't think I do
I you'd have to give me a very specific
example of that
I'm very sure I don't do you think that
your attitude maybe or the way that you
come across towards women is a little
bit maybe insulting towards women or you
know I know you inspire a lot of man
yeah 50 of my audience are women and I
want to train them up and Empower them
as well so I'm I'm mindful of I
understand you understand what I'm
saying yeah I think people who watch my
content in its long form understand that
I talk about being a protector and a
provider for women yeah you do I
truthfully believe that men and women
are very different I don't think we're
the same I think we're very different I
don't think one is better than the other
I just think that the reason the world a
lot of the problems we're in today is
based on the fact that we're forgetting
that men and women are slightly
different
I think a lot of the problems can be
brought back to that very simple point I
think women are better than men at a lot
of things
I think men are better than women at
some things and that's what I say yeah
and I say in some scenarios I would
trust a man and in some scenarios I
trust a woman and I don't believe
they're interchangeable and exactly the
same and I think in most of the world
that's accepted as complete truth in
most of the world they'll accept that
woman is better at this and a man is
better at this and if you work together
you're a perfect partnership and harmony
I don't mean to be disparaging or
insulting to women
uh but I will say the truth I will tell
the truth I will I will not sit and lie
to the world I'll say what I truly
believe I just think we'll do different
things and I think that that's how the
world Works in most of the world today
when it comes to business business
listen men make money women make money
making women making money is fine men
have advantages women have advantages
business just proves my point further
the advantages that women have in
business are different than the
advantages men have in business I knew
when I was in sales jobs women who were
very beautiful who did fantastic in
sales they could use Beauty and going on
that they could get all the appointments
they wanted oh it was hard for me to get
a guy to come to dinner they could get
the dinners they could get the dinners
all day I don't know how good they were
at sales they may not have been as good
as some of the other people in the
office but they got so many more leads
that they closed more her Adventure her
advantages were different than the man's
advantages right so
saying that men and women are different
is not disperging or insulting to either
one of them
there's been I've been making videos on
the internet for a long time
sure I can't sit here and honestly say
because I'm a professional I don't lie I
can't sit here and honestly say I didn't
say at some point hey this [ __ ] came
in with this [ __ ] when I'm telling a
story I probably did say that but I tell
you I insult men just as much just the
same it's not gendered and if you watch
my my stories I probably say this [ __ ]
was running her mouth I probably do say
that I also say in this dick I got hit
so it's not about man and woman it's
just about some people who [ __ ] and
idiots that's that's what it's about
it's not about it's not gendered about
men and women all the women who are in
my life and any woman who's anywhere
near me is very protected very provided
for
it's a traditional gender role where I
believe that all the money making
responsibility is on me now if I met a
woman who was making a bunch of money
I'm not gonna be like damn it stop I
feel good yeah do it but it's just it's
interesting that with my training
business 50 of women yeah you know and
and they're smashing it well I think
that women would also be very very good
at property obviously I don't know
anything about it like you but I think
when it comes to things like interior
design or taking the time to be more
meticulous about how it particularly
looks decorating I'm talking sales
systemization marketing amazing amazing
well and my wife when we when I got
married my net worth was about 500 Grand
within seven years of being married my
net worth was 20 million we're business
partners at this point I don't think
women can't make money I don't know I I
and I'm not surprised that half of the
women who work for you who work with you
make a bunch of money I'm not surprised
like I said about 20 of the people
inside of my University are women I
think that my advertising style is more
geared to men because I talk about men's
issues but the reason I talk about men's
issues is because I'm a man why would I
sit here and talk about how hard it is
to be a girl I can talk about why I
think it's difficult to be a girl but I
can't talk about growing up as a girl
because I'm not a girl
I might have just misgendered myself
sorry YouTube but I'm not a girl I don't
know and so have you got like one
girlfriend who you see as a life partner
I hope I don't understand get you in
trouble with your girlfriends that watch
this at home I'm a man of God I'm a
Christian man and I live true but
Christianity believes in marriage bro
that's it yeah I'm married then
I mean you live with your brother don't
you how does that work out is that like
a long term when you're 60 70 you're
gonna live with your bro and be sleeping
with loads of young girls
I wouldn't say yeah okay first firstly I
don't know what you mean by Young
um attractive yeah and and
attractiveness and youth are linked to a
degree
but yeah I will be living with my
brother forever because I think that uh
masculine competition is a healthy
environment for to bring out the best in
yourself if you look at any fighter
who's training for a fight he's not
going to live with his wife he's going
to live with other men you're gonna live
the last few weeks before a fight Mike
Tyson whatever would move away from
their wife and live with in the house
with just guys like it's kind of like
the Army mentality it's good for your
mentality if you want to be the absolute
Peak version of yourself
I think that you can achieve that by
being in a competitive environment with
other competitive men if I live with
just a woman which sometimes obviously I
do if I stay with a woman it's very
comfortable
it's very comfortable it's a great place
like just food she's nice let's watch TV
oh calm down don't worry it's very
comforting place which is great but I
don't think that Comfort brings out the
Best in Me whereas if I live with my
brother he's like I've just done 600
push-ups you're a [ __ ] then I have to
do 601. maybe
602.600 he's interested and then and
that's it and there's competitiveness if
I'm if I'm hanging with my boys and
we're all talking about how much money
we made that week it pisses me off I'm
gonna hang on my girl we don't talk
about that really or if we do we're on
the same team so it's different you know
to be the to be the best version of
yourself you need competition well
without competitiveness without
competition how are you going to be the
best version of yourself right you're
always going to do better and and run
further and push harder against someone
else so having that friendly competitive
element is how you become the best
version of yourself so that's why I like
living with my brother for that reason
do you not think though if you found
a woman who you could be your business
partner with and do not think that can
you never say just getting married being
with one woman having kids having a
family home living close to your brother
my brother lives too many walk away from
me we're business partners he's got his
family I got my family does that not
appeal to you at all is there nothing
about that where you think you know what
maybe
God has a plan yeah we will see